so guys it's lovely to see you here
tonight at the Sundance Film Festival
with the premiere of the raid tune I
know you get to do your very first car
chase in this movie how was that
stressful stressful upon belief yeah
it's tough I mean you know cuz we're
we're we're dealing with an unknown
element when you have done nine in Asia
before we had a good team come in we
brought in Bruce Lowe stunt team from
Hong Kong to help us with the shoot so
yeah it was we had a lot of technical
help and execution of the stunts but we
weren't helped by the fact that when you
booked those locations you don't get
them for the amount of time you want
them to be so we're always like down by
about 50% of our shooting time every
single day so yeah it gets hard to get
stuff but yeah we go through it but yeah
and believe he spoke to somebody he
worked on a little bit of a bigger
budget action movie that involved a lot
of car chases as well didn't he at the
time well I spoke to somebody was in one
yeah Jojo was talking about fast four
six and we were still shooting our car
chase when this was came out coming out
and so he was like begging me to go and
see it you said please go and see it go
and see this film I want you to support
the film and I was pretty much done like
just leave me the [ __ ] alone because I
wanted to finish my one first because
you know how can we compete like we
don't have the same budget level we got
like sixty seven cars maximum and if
they if they break halfway through why
do we do that and I don't know what
we're gonna do with it so we had six
cars for the entire scene and Eve ran
over six cars in a tank in space the
10sec and say yeah we can't compete with
that so what we try to do is to focus on
you know focus on the people inside the
car so what happens to them when they
crash rather than the actual big
spectacle of going through buildings and
everything else
you spent a month and a half as well
didn't you doing that final fight scene
as well I mean that's there's a lot of
time and care that you spent on that
tell me a little bit about it and how
you felt it went yeah we spent a good
month and a half and now was spent more
on the design so in the pre-production
stage we spent a long time design in it
the shoot itself was about 10 days but
10 days straight so ok for me I'm sat in
a chair but not so good for the guys
because they're fighting constantly so
yeah it's take after take and it's it's
I feel pretty strongly now that I think
it's it's probably the best thing we've
done the final fight
so I'm excited see that pretty
impressive so far so that's something to
say
yeah you know I'd Safari yeah so but I
think I think it tops the final fight of
the last film so I'm excited for people
to see it now so yeah now what are you
take going to take from raid two working
on that into raid three that you've
learned um okay that's a good question
and it's hard me to answer it without
spoiling what we're going to do in the
raid three before you see the rate too
but there's some things I've learned on
some things which are going to be
completely completely different so rate
three is going to be its own thing I
wanted to feel like each film in that
trilogy is totally different from the
other one but just keeps the same
University keep saying characters so
tonally and style wise it'll be
completely different
yeah okay so spoiler hedge for anyone
who's listening your house it seemed
Road to you but I've heard I think for
your Twitter is the road to obviously we
know when that's like two hours after
the first one I'm right three it's
actually gonna be two hours before the
end of the second one so how's that
gonna work it branches off there's a key
moment that happens towards the end of
the film that we come back to and
explore more and that kick starts a
whole other chain of events and so yeah
so does this mean we might get kind of
spin-offs along different lines as well
as well as the raid tree no I think I
think to be honest like after part three
I'm done with that there's a franchise
like I mean I got one more filming me
for that and if I do this one it'll be a
massive departure so we'll see if people
take to it I'm nervous about that one
I mean shot that one only written now
and I'm nervous about it already kind of
timeline we look at that one for then I
won't be for a few years yet I want to
do a couple films outside first and try
to get a little bit more experience and
then come back and do the power 3 then
how likely we're gonna see another comic
book adaptation for the raid 2 and then
raid 3 I'd love to do a comic book
adaptation for it and if I get to do
that one hopefully soon I'd love to do
one which kind of expands even
everything that we have in the sequel to
so like hammer going baseball Batman I
do their origins like every character
that's a present and that we get to know
a little bit more about them and expand
it out so it feels like a novel rather
than the adaptation of a film it's a
little bit we mentioned there already
hammer girl and baseball bat fantastic I
love the names already
I'm terrible it is all I did was just so
basically figure out what sex thing
weapon they use that's all I had so yeah
knife point next maybe I don't know I'm
terrible yeah like that they're cool
characters like I wanted I wanted
something that kind of like skirted the
line of being a comic book style but
still maintains the sort of feeling of
reality so it doesn't kind of like
stretch the borders too much doesn't
kind of feel too far-fetched
so yeah fingers crossed we've done that
so it still fits within our action
design but yeah pushing the boundaries a
little bit and maybe a little bit of
crack but when Marvel comes knocking in
the future I don't know what I see see
what happens what stages we have with
the english-language remake of both
right I'm guessing there's gonna be one
for right two and three as well I mean
you'd have to ask exercise you guys were
that to be honest like they're more
involved in that than I am I'm involved
into a part up to a point but I'm just
kind of you know focused on just this
one at the moment so we'll see once this
is all done I can start to chase up a
little more information maybe and of
course you've got the night comes for us
as well next with you
teaming back up with Timo after VHS -
what can we look forward to with that
well Tim was a maniac and I loved
working with him I love him to bits like
he's crazy
and we're working on designing action
seems to fit his style so I'm a little
worried about that because he's a little
more violent than me
so if that's possible but yeah he's a
great guy and we're super excited and
he's like the only person that I would
trust with our company so you know when
it comes to this film yeah it's it's
gonna be me producing him direct and
then me echoing iron will handle the
action choreography Joe TASM in the lead
and it's like an wash hitman thriller
type stuff so it's gonna be a bit
crazier you've got a lot of the same
people back again for that haven't you
yeah I mean like these are guys that we
trust and guys that we love working with
I mean like you know as long as as long
as no one's an [ __ ] on set we work
with him again so yeah and we joked
around because like Jo Jo Jo's in this
movie but only in photograph form so
whenever we get asked about I always say
guys since he's gone Hollywood we can't
afford him anymore no we love him to
bits and we're gonna just tailor make
the next one to be a massive vehicle for
him so he's gonna get to use all his
judo skills and like you know some MMA
and grappling and finance officers gonna
be great
now I wanted to ask because I know he's
spoken in the past about how you've done
some
sell out yourself by wended i wondered
how would you cope if you found yourself
in grandma's situation um in the first
film both of them I wouldn't have made
it to the second one so yeah III I'd
have been one of the guys who got shot
on the get-go so yeah I wouldn't go oh
now and what are you looking forward to
about tonight in particular go uh it's
finishing I'm really I'm really excited
to see how it plays um yeah it's just I
don't know once it's it's fun it's like
this is an exciting moment they mean
it's nerve-racking as hell because like
you just don't know how people can
respond you have no idea how they're
gonna react so yeah we'll just we'll
just see how it goes you know and just
I'm hoping they like it as much the
sacrum it's so so different so so
unusual compared to the first movie so
I'm kind of hoping that they'll go along
for the ride
so we'll see are you looking forward to
something that fight in the mud that
you've been through it's time recruiting
riot yeah yeah the prison warhead was
insane I lost a pair of shoes in the mud
so yeah yeah everyone lost stuff in the
mud but yeah it was um there's a cool
experience it was hard work it was eight
days in the mud and tough choreography
and also I mean like we're falling I'm
around we don't change our camera
movement you know so we still stick into
that all Roman feeling of the cameras so
you do long takes long takes long takes
and then right at the last moment
somebody will hit and mud will hit the
lens so then all sudden you go go again
but yeah technically it was difficult
emotionally devastated but I gather that
we were all good but once you see the
cuts every day then start to feel worth
it then so yeah how long did it take you
to recover from making the movie I
haven't yet still making it so yeah I
know it's been fun great day well Gareth
load the blur tonight not that you need
it I'm sure everyone's gonna love it
thanks I hope so thank you so much
you